THE DECISION BY THE
NINTH CIRCUIT COURT OF APPEALS
UPHOLDS A LOWER COURT RULING.
THE DEMOCRATIC PRESIDENT WHO
CONTROL FIELD GREW BY TWO
YESTERDAY, BOTH WOMEN SERVING IN
THE U.S. SENATE.
THEY JOIN AN EVER EXPANDING
FIELD THEY COULD SOON FEATURE A
RELATIVE NEWCOMER WHO IS MAKING
PLENTY OF NOISE.
HERE'S CORRESPONDENT
PETER DOOCY.
>> BETTA IS BACK AND FINDING OUT
IF HE CAN STILL GENERATE THE
SAME KIND OF BUZZ THAT DREW
TEXANS BY THE THOUSANDS WHO SAW
HIM COMPETE IN THE SENATE IN THE
FALL.
>> EL PASO, I LOVE YOU SO MUCH.
>> O'ROURKE'S HAD LIGHTING IN
THE EVENT CALLING MARCH FOR
TRUTH: STOP THE TRUTH, STOP THE
LIES."
"
BEEFED UP SECURITY AT PORTS OF
ENTRY, AND AN END TO THE GLOBAL
WAR ON DRUGS.
>> WE WILL MEET LIES IN THE
HAIGHT WITH THE TRUTH AND THE
VISION FOR THE FUTURE FROM THE
U.S.-MEXICO BORDER.
>> O'ROURKE IS PROTESTING
PRESIDENT TRUMP, BUT ELIZABETH
WARREN SAYING A PRESIDENT TRUMP
MIGHT NOT BE ON THE BALLOT NEXT
YEAR.
>> BY THE TIME WE GET TO 2020,
DONALD TRUMP MAY NOT EVEN BE
PRESIDENT.
HE MAY NOT EVEN BE A FREE PERSO
PERSON.
>> CORY BOOKER IS TESTING A LESS
PROVOCATIVE APPROACH.
>> OUR POLITICS CANNOT BECOME
ONE OF PITTING EACH OTHER
AGAINST EACH OTHER.
THEY CANNOT BE WHINED ABOUT
TRASH TALKING AND TROLLING.
>> AMICABLE CHAR WAS ANONYMOUSLY
ACCUSED OF DEGRADING SOME
STAFFERS, BUT SETTING THE RECORD
STRAIGHT.
>> I AM TOUGH.
I PUSH PEOPLE.
THAT IS TRUE.
I HAVE HIGH EXPECTATIONS FOR
MYSELF.
I HAVE HIGH EXPECTATIONS FOR THE
PEOPLE WHO WORKED FOR ME.
>> AMY CLOVER CHAR SAYS SHE HAS
KAMALA HARRIS SAYS SHE'S BEEN
HIGH.
>> HAVE YOU SMOKED?
>> I HAVE.
AND I INHALE.
I DIDN'T INHALE.
>> WHAT A DIFFERENCE TO AN A
HALF DECADES MAKES FOR
DEMOCRATS.
>> I EXPERIMENTED WITH MY
ALANA     MARIJUANA A TIMER TO I
DIDN'T LIKE IT.
I DIDN'T INHALE.
>> IF SHE WINS, SHE WANTS TO BE
THE PRESIDENT WHO LEGALIZES IT.
>> LOOK, I JOKE ABOUT IT.
HALF OF MY FAMILY IS FROM
JAMAICA.
ARE YOU KIDDING ME?
>> SOME OF THESE CANDIDATES NO
LONGER AFRAID TO ADMITTING TO
MARIJUANA USE, COULD MAKE THEIR
CAMPAIGNS GO UP IN SMOKE WITH
DEMOCRATIC PARTIES PLATFORM
FOCUSED ON MEDICARE FOR ALL